hello everyone and welcome to a game
that was placed today in the Dutch Open
Championship it's again between a
Russian Grand Master VHS la vie
Kournikova and the German freedom master
Rhino Odin doll and it's a game that you
will not see happen very often maybe you
will between maybe lower rated players
but have another very open between a
video master and a Grand Master so
without further ado let's just check it
out and I would just like to mention
that for those of you who have
downloaded and enjoyed my chess clock
application for Android that's the same
is now available also for iOS so now you
know do do check it out do download it I
will put a link in the description below
it will be the first thing you see so do
check it out and I I don't have an Apple
device so I can try it out for myself
but you know my the gentleman who
developed the DF says that it should be
working properly like the Android
version so feel free to you know send
your send your feedback and also on the
App Store you can also just send your
feedback and suggestions directly to him
at the mystery even Armitage so getting
back to the game
Odin doll plays c4 so the English is on
the board we have c5 g3 g6 and the Finn
carrying of the bishops Bishop g2 Bishop
g7 so we have the symmetrical variation
of the English knight of three Knight to
c6 and now ordinal castles with d6
by by equina cove with Knight to c3 just
developing East 6 and now d3 and here
knife gt7 black is also not ready to
castle rugby 1 you want to get your look
away from this diagonal as soon as
possible you want to play a 3 B 4
grab some space on the Queen side with
castles buy black and now brush up the
b2 I'm just continuing development and
now b6 also preparing to maybe Finn get
to the light square bishop with a three
white prepares before and now Bishop to
b7 opposing White's strong light square
bishop and now white continues to expand
on the Queen side with b4 and Queen to
d7 now Queen to a4 there's no really
threat with this Queen to a4 move but
you can't really move your
right since your queen here is unguarded
and well the bishop is also here so you
know if you're not careful something
could happen but there is no actual
threat at the moment so black just
continues h6 and now there is one game
in the database for rook after the one
was played but here we have look after
c1 by Odin doll and it is now as of most
thirteen that we have a completely new
game on our hands
so black continues with g5 he wants to
play g4 cause trouble for white on the
King side and now we have III with rook
F to d8 and now comes h4 just trying to
take advantage of the of the you know
the Jeep one that is quite weak now but
now black just advances that we have g4
attacking the knight and the Knights to
e1 and here Knight to g6 black is now
ready to further expand he wants to play
F v e5 and start an attack with f4 so
Queen to d1 now white says okay my queen
is I'm not really doing anything here so
better just to get her back into the
game Queen 31 and now as the G point is
under attack
you have f5 so just defending it Quinta
e 2 and now look back to f8 so the the
break will be further supported after E
5 and therefore has been played Queen to
f1 and now we have rook a to c8 so if
the positions were position opens up the
rook will be ready there with Knights
the b5 again there's no actual threat
but you have to be somewhat careful for
example if the Queen leaves the 7th rank
you can play something like Knight
captures on a 7 and then if the Knight
captures the bishop will be unguarded
but as long as the Queen is here there
is no threat here but the bishop the AAT
just to be safe now the Queen also keeps
an eye on the a7 pawn with Bishop to c3
now offering to exchange dark square
Bishop s' as blacks dark square Bishop
was much better than whites dark square
bishop and black of course denies white
this idea with E 5 now preparing f4 be
captors on c5 we have D captures on c5
still keeping an eye on the d4 square
and now rush back to a 1 the base will
be very safe there and also you have a
square for your Knights to retreat to if
needed if black
for example with a six and black weights
no longer with ff4 so now what do you
play yeah you don't really gain anything
by capturing if you capture black just
recaptures and then well again f3 can be
played upon captors and g3 can be played
any bit after let's say check King h8
and now a nice trade of bishops you
still have problems here you don't
really have a good way to deal with this
Blackwell chapter on g3 and open up well
the safety of your king so after f4 we
have Bishop to d5 check first King to h8
and now comes Queen to d2 so what do you
play here with f3 just grabbing more
space on the Kings side and now you can
already see that there are some ideas on
the Kings side with Queen to c2 now
getting the Queen out of the way and
here what do you play here 90 G to e7
was played challenging the bishop on d5
but also possible was just Knight
captures on h4 after G captures 97 now
you created this threat with the
LightSquared bishop and after bishops
are traded then you continue playing the
game whatever white place let's say you
want to bring a knight into the game g3
is the idea now the Queen can come over
to h3 you can capture on h4 start
pushing the h1 it's gonna be very
dangerous but black decides the further
prepare this with nice to East 7 bishop
to the bishop to e4 and now Knight to f5
so the idea is still there only now
white gets to eliminate the knife first
so bunch of characters with rook
captures and now Knight back to c3 but
now rook back to f7 clearing the f4
square for the other night now the the
idea is Knight a 7 back to f5 and now
white will have some issues dealing with
this night so what do you play here with
Knight the e4 and here the black
continues with his plan Knight to e7
well rook to d1 still white is dreaming
of pushing d4 at some point but it's
very hard to imagine how such a thing
could happen with Knight to f5 again
positioning the knight perfectly and now
Queen to b3 Queen to b3 probably with an
idea of nice to see - and then the from
c2 the night
also be supporting the d4 square so here
white really wants to push d4 as it is
the only breakthrough white can make in
the position so rook seat the f8 now
black doubles up on the FS so you can
already feel that something is really
cooking on the claim the King side with
night the c2 now really preparing d4 and
now black waits no longer with Knight
captures on h4g captures on h4 and now
g3 already the idea is squint h3
followed by Queen to G to checkmate
so white of course doesn't want to mess
up his pawn structure he plays Knight
captures and g3 and we have Queen to h3
and here
Knights that you want this is the only
move that prevents checkmate Queen g2 is
the thread so 91 now here feel free to
pause the video and you know find the
best move for black and really it's a
it's a really a crazy position while I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who found Queen captures on g3
congratulations that is exactly the move
that if you actually love iconic of
played and you know he decided to finish
the game in great style and indeed he
played Queen captures and g3 and it was
in this position that his opponent RINO
odenthal
resigned the game now what's weird about
this is that Queen to g3 doesn't
actually win the game you can win the
game in in for example by capturing on
h4 and then ok you can move the Queen to
g5 and start pushing your H pawn and
this is a clean win for black but after
this Queen captures ng to remove it
doesn't matter since his opponent
resigned but this actually loses the
game for black now it's very interesting
what mr. odenthal saw in this position
that he decided to resign it is a very
nice position for black but still if you
don't have made or some you know
significant material gain it's just a
blunder
you've just wondered the Queen so here
what happens if the queen is accepted of
course you don't have any other options
if you don't accept the Queen you're
getting made it so pawn captures and g3
and of course blacks on the idea to
continue the attack is f2 check now of
course you have to go King f1 otherwise
if you go for example h2 then just point
to f1 brings another Queen into the game
so you have to go King f1 now
get pawn captures night with check
getting a queen in three game King
captures anyone and now how do you
continue the attack for example if you
continue rook F 1 King Ditu you have
looked F to check now the King starts
running away King to c3 and now okay you
even have a discovered check
efore but now black defend a white
defense with D for we have pawn captures
the width check now you don't want to
capture here to allow and in rook to
have three ideas so just run away with
the King King Tubby for now you get
Bishop to f8 check and you play c5 now
and after B captors on c5 you just play
King to b5
there are no more checks and here you
are just down Queen there's no way for
black to continue the attack and as soon
as white gets a move in it's going to be
just over and there's no way to prevent
the trade of rooks and it's it's over
for black so it's really amazing I mean
it's quite a king walk but like I said
if you don't have made it's just a
blunder and another idea for example
after King captures only one after this
line you could try something like a
mushroom to c6 prevent this walk and the
King coming to b5 so for example if you
had a rook f1 now thinks maybe it would
have been different but still the white
king can still just hide on c1 for
example you can immediately start
running away King Teddy to look after
checking see one there are no more
checks the attack is over and well
that's that's all there is
so really amazing game and it
immediately reminded me I saw it just
when he first tweet about this game that
it's very unfortunate how how I decided
to resign after Queen Katherine g3 and
yes it is very unfortunate but still you
know it does happen it reminds me of
this one game a colleague of mine from
my chess club it was maybe some ten
years ago he resigned he saw that his
opponent was winning a piece and you
know okay he resigned you know he was
the game and then after when I was you
know just going through the games that
some of my colleagues from my chess club
played I found that game and I decided
to see it and I was like whoa okay yes
he loses a piece but he has made in five
so say it's not you know identical
situation but it's
you should never trust your opponent I
don't know what are your thoughts on
what happened here why did he resign did
he just decide to trust the Grand Master
as he was completely lost in this
position so maybe when the Grand Master
played Queen Catherine g3 he just
decided yeah okay I even didn't consider
this a little better just resign maybe
there was a lot of audience and maybe
who knows what now I think at the moment
it was like he had over four minutes on
the clock so I think there was a the
possibility of actually calculating it
out it's really just incredible that
such a thing can happen in a game
between a feedom master and and the
Grandmaster but yeah really just insane
I I do hope you enjoyed it I'm sure mr.
Reiner odenthal
didn't and yeah if you if you wanted to
check out the eigen amount of chess
clock it is now available for for Apple
iOS so do check it out and give us some
of the feedback as like I said I haven't
tried it yet I have no idea if
everything is working properly and also
I would just like to mention it's a
version for the Apple smartphone it's
not yet available for the iPad it will
be in some ten days so I've been told
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank a Jody
pallet for a contribution to my channel
thanks a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thankful for watching and I
will see you soon checking up on your
suggestions continuing the cup of Wonka
saga and covering whatever is happening
in the world such as this beauty here
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day